it has been ten years since your time on
the show I think 11 I'm super old like
really really really old very young no
one would know no how would you say the
show has changed since your time on it
oh my god - social media in general has
changed the show and really just the way
the show is viewed from a like an
audience perspective it just is really
different social media just changes
everything people go on the show to sell
teeth whitener now you know so that's
really cool back in the day when you
have MySpace so you know I think it's
gotten even more dramatic hannah season
just ended we see it didn't work out for
her did it work out for you either but
you found your happy ending yes what's
your advice to Hannah moving into this
next chapter I don't think Hannah needs
my advice whatsoever because now she's
on Dancing with the Stars so we're all
super jealous you know what I think that
the best advice that Hannah could get
like going through this I'm moving
forward is just to stay true to herself
and who she is because I think Hollywood
can suck you up and make you cry yeah
yeah but I think as long as she stays
true to who she is and what she wants I
think she'll do really really great and
our next Bachelor
pilot Pete yeah how do we feel about
Pete we've already had one pilot well
thank you guys so well I think as long
as Pete stays clear of windmills the
season could be really successful for
sure go into more windmills well please
then it would become like Flavor Flav
and that's just not cute but there was a
little outrage that it wasn't Mike who
made it there because we have not had a
Bachelor of color yet why don't you
think the franchise has had a Bachelor
of color
I think it would be really hard to
choose Mike when he's dating demi lovato
because I don't think demi is going to
sign up to be on The Bachelor let's be
honest
alright didn't run with it no get Demi
in there have her have her Pfeiffer
roses that's it
it could be the epitome of her career I
mean if we're being for real I think
Mike is gonna be just fine
yes I think he's doing okay okay all
right wrap things up here you did get to
do a big Bachelorette reunion this year
everyone loved it any plans for more of
those people on boat I feel like if I
could fit every last Bachelorette in our
house I would do it every single Friday
night for a slumber party I said this is
even a thousand times it was one of the
most favorite parts of my year because I
sincerely love all of those women and we
get along really well and I just thought
what a beautiful moment in 15 seasons of
The Bachelorette to bring all of us
women together and you know what else is
like will support one another we all
love each other and we're all happy for
each other and the way their careers
have grown and changed throughout the
season so I just love those women I
gotta say the bachelorettes have staying
power people remember them not so much
because we're realistic we don't get on
the show and were like oh my god all
these women want me let's just do
whatever we're realistic about what is
happening oh I don't have a comment I'm
just gonna stand here and look pretty to
round things up what's the secret to
making this work why is this been a
successful relationship
[Music]
I think that marriage is really hard and
I think that when you add two children
three children however many children you
have into marriage it is very hard but I
think at the end of the day when you are
committed to one another no matter what
is going on or what problems you're
going through I think that is with what
is most important and at the center of
all the Lord is what is important to us
and that's where we keep our baby yeah
and I think laughter is just the big
piece of it as well being able to have
fun together and laugh through these
nights you would never know that we hate
each other right now right I know I'm
just kidding yeah I think laughter is
really at the end of the day if there's
still love and you didn't kill the
children you made it there surviving so
we're great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]